[Music]
hey what's up you guys Denny here this
is so exciting this welcome to the very
first alive daily Denny um if you guys
are a fan of the show or a fan of our
bachelor recap show roses and rosy then
you know this got us to my left miss
Lauren Zima I cannot believe I managed
to weasel myself into the first live
daily Denny I feel so lucky and blessed
you're Loco shameless plug there's a new
roasted rib a I'm gonna be taping
tonight we have live tomorrow hang on
for 90 seconds anyways you guys thanks
so much for joining us or she we heard
both here to give you guys a recap of
last night's Golden Globes and what you
didn't see on TV oh what a night it was
amazing amazing amazing night a lot of
people out there obviously if you guys
didn't get the memo all the actresses
all the actors everyone at the Golden
Globes wore black yesterday in
solidarity for the times movement it was
really powerful what did you think so
powerful you guys I was on the red
carpet and then we have been glued we've
barely slept you all of ETS reporting
that we're getting from behind the
scenes from the after parties so we're
gonna tell you everything that went down
that you didn't see on TV but yeah I
even being on the carpet I have to say
so usually you guys the way a red carpet
works is it's pretty linear people go
down the carpet and they talk to et
first of course and then you know outlet
after outlet but at a certain point they
got to go inside this year as I was
watching people come down the carpet
these women wanted to make sure that
they spoke to as many media outlets as
they could to spread their message and
everybody was in such a great mood
because people were so passionate about
what they were talking about the vibe of
the carpet if you were there was
different than any other awards show
I've ever done I mean I think the
biggest signs of how different this
year's Golden Globes were especially on
the red carpet without a lot of stars
actually opted to bring female activists
very prominent female activists as their
date to the Golden Globes among them
Emma Stone who brought Billie Jean Keene
of course she played Billie Jean King in
battle the sexes when she was nominated
for there they are on the red carpet
right there and then Susan Sarandon also
brought Puerto Rican activist rosette
Clement Clemente excuse me and so like
you've mentioned I feel like for the
first time we saw a lot of actresses who
were very um they were very vocal but
also made sure they stopped by everybody
with the person on the right to spread
their message I look at them right
that's Susan and Rosa yeah then we had
Michelle Williams with a Toronto Burke
who was
me too original founder you guys
probably saw the me to campaign on
Twitter she actually started it even
before it kind of had a resurgence this
year so Michelle Williams you guys I got
to tell you we've interviewed her before
she's you she's my private yeah shy
person I've never seen her like this on
a carpet so talkative so vocal and again
making her way down making sure to talk
to everybody and et spoke with her Kevin
Frazier talked to her kind of about how
the future of women is even living in
her own household as she raises her
daughter here's what she'll had to say
Toronto did you understand what you
started and where it is now and to be
here at the Golden Globes at this moment
[Music]
and then it kept growing and kept
growing and eventually we got to this
moment but I could never have dreamed
that it would get here Michelle why is
it important for you to walk this carpet
tonight what's wrong you know I thought
that I would have to raise my daughter
to learn how to protect yourself and
defend herself against the world and
what I've realized is that it's actually
possible and I believe it with all my
heart because of the work of women like
tirana that we can hand our daughters a
different world and so I'm full of like
optimism tonight an enthusiasm that we
can make a change it's going to be
permanent and lasting for all of our
children it's run you know so many
people say that all these Hollywood
folks they're so privileged they don't
connect with the average person but here
tonight for the rest of the answer
anybody even online.com but I mean that
really was the theme and the tone of the
night this there's this feeling of
optimism of hope especially after
Oprah's speech and certainly enthusiasm
for for the message that ever was
spreading on that on that night yeah and
you could see it in Michelle's answer
there I you could see the light in her
face you guys I'm telling you she is
someone where she just doesn't really
open up very much and to hear her talk
that much in to hear to talk about her
hope for the future it really I mean as
I said this last night and I recap I
teared up a couple times on the red card
because it really did and also of course
we want to know what you guys thought of
whether the show struck the right tone
last night as we're kind of going
through everything so leave your
comments oh they're coming in Aaron B
said she loves seeing Natalie Portman in
Arik America forever
while the red carpet together Linda says
my favorite moment was seeing Angelina
Jolie oh we're gonna get into who
brought her son which I thought was
awesome yeah so cool I mean obviously
it's the Golden Globes it's one of the
only award shows were film and TV are
walking the same carpet at the same
ceremony so there's some really fun
run-ins and also some cast members we
haven't seen each other in a very long
time you know you shoot this stuff and
then it's over and you guys get to
reunite on the carpet among them your
face big that's my Oprah version of the
show you guys so I was standing right
there and here's the thing what a
perfect year again for big little lies
to have happened a show all about women
Reese Witherspoon helping spearhead The
Times up movement the big little lies
cast loves the crap out of each other so
I saw shailene woodley and Reese
Witherspoon see each other on the red
carpet here's the moment what you're not
seeing there I mean looking to Cole
Kidman smiling over her besties what
you're not seeing is Shailene literally
went like screamed out surround the
carpet they run over to each other as
you can kind of see them embrace in that
photo so it's just friends seeing each
other I'm excited it was awesome and
then they spend the whole night together
we know they're at the show together
they're hitting the stages they're
winning those awards they hit all the
party after party yes it was a big
little lies night and also got some
season to scoop get this season when
director Jean Monnet told me that we are
going to see Perry's mom as a character
in season 2 who that could be though to
play okay well we found out one person
who it isn't a TV online.com to find out
let's not be on the show actress said no
I will not be part of it even though
people are calling for her to be that's
Annie time right back calm are you guys
some other fun run-ins you didn't see on
TV happen on the et platform where one
of the first positions on the red carpet
and just to paint a picture for you guys
it's an actual platform with stairs
there's only one way up and one way down
so there's bound to be some a-list
run-ins among them this one's really
cute you guys Halle Berry having a
moment with mary j blige after she
wrapped her interview with Kevin Frazier
clearly they haven't seen each other in
a while and um I studied this clip and
was tryna cuz there's no audio so I was
trying to read their lips
Holly was congratulating Mary for her
amazing performance and mud bound I'm
using the word amazing I don't think she
did but she was just like full of
gratitude and they chat for a little bit
on that on the platform right there
another one was between Sarah Jessica
Parker and Lady Bird director director
Greta Gerwig clearly SJP here is
fangirling over Greta and um if I were
Sarah I'd be asking to be in her next
project or like have her director
episode of divorce what do you think
they were I mean they were talking
fashion they were talking like you know
again just being there tonight and can I
just say I mean women turning it out in
black everybody looks good in black
which is amazing but Halle Berry could
you look any better she was stunning and
I loved what she told Kevin oh well we
all kind of pulled together guys here's
a little BTS thing we all pull together
and help each other come up with
questions for awards shows like this
because there's so many people we have
to interview so I was blessed to try to
work on our questions for Halle Berry
and I said Kevin you have to ask her
what she's talking about in 2018 because
on her Instagram how he's like I'm
coming for you 2018 and she talked about
how she's coming for her career like
Halle is not messing around in 2018 the
word she used was like I'm in beast mode
I'm oh yeah East 2018
hashtag beast mode 2018 I love the limit
and I just need to know all of her
secrets for her whole life because she
looks amazing she's so full of life
she's literally Benjamin Button she's
aging are you guys let's move inside the
ballroom for the actual award show
obviously it was a very long telecast
but a lot of amazing moments but here's
some stuff you guys probably didn't
catch number one mr. Tom Hanks
apparently is a pal and a bartender in a
previous life because he brought a tray
of martinis to his table
well that Stephen that's just Tom makes
is delivering some martinis to mr.
Steven Spielberg and I love the small
world of Hollywood you guys here's who
tweeted this photo this is us creator
Dan Fogelman you know he's in the room
and it kind of went viral because
there's also people got photos of Tom
Hanks waiting at the bar to get the
drinks that's the thing about the Globes
the alcohol is flowing but hey even Tom
Hanks has to get his own drink I don't
think they've got waiters walking around
so everybody's like if you didn't
already love Tom Hanks
he's that friend who goes and gets
drinks for the whole table man after my
own heart
I love that but wouldn't you be taking
that photo too if you saw that hi oh
Forrest Gump is walking with the dirties
I love it like Seth Meyers I loved how
he made that comment which I'm sticking
to Oprah for president and Tom Hanks is
VP I'm here for it yes
also if you guys don't follow Rita
Wilson on Instagram booboo is the back
she is hilarious she's like here's what
our table looks like she's it's like
she's your adorable mom but this
incredible celebrity married to Tom
Hanks taking you inside the Globes on
Instagram so check her which by the way
pops to that table because the only sir
champagne at the actual table they
wanted some hard stuff Keith says if
Oprah did run for president who should
be her vice Tom Hanks yes I got my vote
okay so another moment you guys missed
Mariah Carey right Carey was nominated
for her song in the star apparently she
took a little bathroom break and on her
way back they came back from commercial
break so she took the first seat she saw
you'll never guess whose it was
of all people Meryl Streep ha ha Mariah
tweeted about the moment and she says
'my dear Meryl please forgive me Meryl
Streep you could take my seat any time
loving reuse of parentheses there I was
gonna see the script that's like Mariah
Carey is someone who writes the moment
she wants to have she's manifesting it
that moment's gonna be nominated for
best short film at the office but I mean
let's talk about it of Mariah Carey
accidentally sitting in Meryl Streep's
seat you guys this is the gloves this we
love awards season all these people
coming together it's amazing that dude
likes her to use to so that's about that
yes ok sterling Brown who was a winner
last night he made history becoming the
first black actor to accept Best Actor
in a Drama at the Golden Globes but he's
also a fanboy - you know we had some
eyes and ears in the ballroom and
apparently he geeked out meeting Game of
Thrones Kit Harington he was heard
telling kit hey man I'm a huge fan and
kit just kind of blessing him and saying
thank you moving on only at the Globes
he's on his way to the bathroom running
into frickin Jon Snow gotta say what's
up I mean you guys let me tell you so we
I like Denny said we have reporters
inside ok the place to hear what's
happening is waiting in line for the
bathroom I used to work for variety and
let me share a story I'm sorry oh oh I
was at Vanity Fair's Oscar party so I
was waiting in line for the bathroom who
did I see having an intimate intense
conversation Taylor Swift and Jake
Gyllenhaal mm-hmm I reported on it at
the time and these are the Pulitzer
winning moments of are speaking of
waiting line in the bathroom are are
what a line what what a segue um all
right I saw Angelina Jolie in line for
the bathroom she waits in line like
everybody else you guys and she was
actually greeting and hugging people and
talking to women in the line for the bet
I wonder what that conversation was like
oh I mean what a liner hopefully well
they got the Dyson Airblade
house how's your work with the UN love
your work okay moving right along you
guys speaking of people who are
starstruck Oh call me by your name
Timothy Shelley made the break out star
of the year we called it here on Daly
Denny um you know he was nominated last
night of course and he was actually
starstruck by a real-life person miss
Tanya Hardy who was at the table for I
Tanya we have a short little clip to
show you in case you guys missed it Oh
actually a screen grab
that's Tonya Harding figure skater
Olympic fan Timothy shook he's so sure
but Olympic skater Tonya Harding is just
a couple of inches a week I think what
happened was they started talking about
you know the movie and talking about Oh
Tanya's here tonight and then he's like
oh you know because she it's been years
since we kind of saw her in the Olympics
attention so obviously if she's not
Margot Robbie she's Tonya Harding for
all he knew she was a producer or
something that he didn't know it oh no
that is actually Tonya Harding she's
here in the room you know I hope he
doesn't lose that that spark you sure
bright eyed him bushy-tailed right now I
mean he was next to Meryl Streep Tom
Hanks and I love that he was he got that
kind of reaction from that Clark says so
proud of the big little eyes posse
yes how much did we love their speeches
last night it was amazing and we have
even more scoop on season 2 you guys we
talked to Nicole Kidman Laura Dern all
about what season 2 is gonna be like so
head to me tonight calm now speaking of
big little lies shailene woodley she was
also in the crowd last night and you
guys there's a lot of people at these
things and she of course ran into her
Fault in Our Stars co-star Ansel Elgort
we have a picture of them together look
at them little reunion that movie
broke me by the way but yeah those two
we actually saw them really nice she
tapped him on the back him a quick
little hug and they post with that photo
I loved it and he instagrammed and wrote
this really sweet message again because
the night was all about women he wrote
about how she guided him early on in her
career I think he said I was just
starting out she was our
Golden Globe nominee she's so talented
and she kind of told him you know here's
how you can approach Hollywood so such a
sweet message from him he's a sweetheart
he was I saw him on the carpet last
night just happy to be there like the
guy is just jamming out I think it was
his first glow yes absolutely for
somebody's nominee for sure for baby
driver yes all right you guys one of the
most talked about moments of the evening
of course belongs to miss Oprah our
future president yeah I really brought
down the house with her acceptance
speech for the sessile B deMille Award
and um you know she spread her wisdom
after that speech wrap back room in the
press room which I mean that's the place
to do it the press basically gets an
opportunity to ask the winners um any
questions they want and one excuse me
one thing the reporter as Oprah was like
after everything that's going on after
looking back on here a long long storied
career what's the one thing you would
tell your younger self here's what she
had to say I was so sad and at seven all
of my real love came from my teachers
and so my teachers I would say this to
anybody in this room you have no idea of
the power of noticing another human
being and what it feels like when
somebody knows that they have been seen
truly seen by you it is the greatest
offering you can give when I was so
where does that come from
Oprah where does that come from I mean
come on can we just give it up for over
okay Oprah I watched her speech three
times and I wanted to share that little
moment backstage because you guys don't
always get to see that but like she's
just a wealth of information that's why
she would write books I mean we lead it
we need these words more now than ever
let me tell you behind the scenes moment
of denne director you guys we're here
late last night where we're doing the
after parties coverage we're making sure
we're ready to go and that were on top
of everything and he goes would anyone
mind if I just watched Oprah speech
again and that played it for everyone I
replayed it that speech should win an
Emmy for her delivery alone on the radio
give her the Grammy for it where is it
ah Spotify viral top 50 is what I
see like that I need it on a loop it's
amazing what you're gonna fall asleep to
that every night it's your new Pledge of
Allegiance
I watched it three times Sharon says
everybody was in a great moves for such
a great cause
time's up and loved over speech yes yes
yes and then we had wreaths doing a
little impression of her pal Oprah I
loved it Rizza of course presented oprah
with the award that she got and then I
think it was backstage in the press room
she gave us a little Oprah impression
here it is yes and do I have an
oppression you get a Golden Globe and
you get a Golden Globe and you get a
Golden Globe everybody gets a golden
glow that's my Oprah that's my Oprah
thank you for that Reese I'm gonna say
that you did a little better than Wow
yeah oh my god I know it's okay play
that during my Kennedy Center Honors
okay oh so yeah obviously Oprah most
talked-about moment of the night and big
after her fiery speech which was such
like I said she delivered so well it was
a very optimistic message of hope right
after that I mean Twitter blew up all
the stars we talked to backstage all the
one thing on their mind was like Oprah
2020 let's get Oprah door one four run
for president it's spreading like
wildfire I know it's so we're kind of
getting a little bit of conflicting
information here guys because everybody
wants Oprah 2020 we know that a reporter
from the LA Times talked to Stedman and
Stedman said if the people want it she'd
consider it we want it so it's a little
all over the place you know when these
people like Mark Cuban or Oprah or even
Donald Trump you know people were kind
of talking about it for years before it
happened so could it happen we actually
did talk to Oprah about it not too long
ago so long ago on the et stage here's
what she had to say you guys why do
people keep wanting you to run for
president what is that I don't know why
would you not want over it around firm
no no no I I'm just curious because
people are saying 2020 now is done yeah
how'd that happen that is just not gonna
happen
okay yeah I just cuz that would not be
my strength my strength is bringing
people together my strength is
connecting people to ideas my strength
is allowing people to see the best of
themselves even than the worst of times
and circumstances that is not my thing
that would not be what I would be able
to do well
politics doesn't do that does it
something doesn't do that for me
but I would get behind somebody who I
really truly believed in and would work
my butt off to to make them as
successful as possible I don't know who
that is right now because I know there's
gonna be a next question so don't go
down it's you Oprah here's the thing
she's describing what what we need she's
saying I would can rally people in the
worst of times yes Oprah it's you by the
way she was promoting her food languages
why they were eating that was a spoon
there yes I love that we start that shot
with Kevin's like emilie's and again
everybody was all about it even the big
little lies cast rista the impression
then the cast was here to campaign for
Oprah here's what they had to say to us
I mean what do you guys have to say
about Oprah's speech I don't think our
leonie they just are going president I
mean everybody talked about Allison
Janney sterling K Brown who by the way
we're told sterling K Brown actually was
backstage with our Kevin Frazier for his
one-on-one interview after he won and
actually stopped so they could watch
Oprah yeah he said I came to the
interview I have to watch Oprah speech
that's what I did you tried to talk to
me during Oprah speech my TV's not
working right now
I had a technical issue I need my work
husband for but my work husband had
another way but that moment it was Oprah
so girl for all people cheat on me with
Oprah so you guys again we are showing
you snippets of everything we got but
watch Entertainment tonight tonight and
head to et online calm because there's
so much more so much great juicy stuff
and scoop and we had the show we had
backstage and then we had the
after-party oh we didn't plan that no we
should go on the road you just left a
sing-off you guys after parties that
brings out a lot of people not just to
be boomer out the Golden Globes case in
point
Drake Drake made the rounds last night
he was like you know what I'm here I got
a straight man invite he throws on a tux
maybe even a hoodie and he's like I want
to get in he made the rounds last night
including at the Netflix party and I
witness tells us that the entire
stranger things cast was hanging out
with Drake and then a huge fans that's
Drake and Millie Bobby Brown Hugh
imagine being Millie Bobby Brown and
just running in a Drake and Drake going
up can be like I'm a big fan I know your
show like that's so exciting
I mean Drake sort of became the
surprising star of the night because get
this not only is the stranger thangs
cast of kids surrounding Jake Drake at a
table but then Angelina Jolie stops him
she has to say hello she has to give him
a smile and you know I don't know
probably tell him she loves him for
whatever reason she Lissa's the hotline
bling' on repeat I don't know I mean it
was this again these amazing unexpected
moments Angelina chatting people in line
for the bathroom Angelina Jolie going up
to Drake social these days yes but you
guys well we don't know if they're into
each other but again it's a small world
of Hollywood what some people are
talking about today is Angelina Jolie
was at the Netflix party and Jennifer
Aniston was there so awkward who knows
what that conversation is like at this
point this is the first award season
since Angelina and Brad have split up we
don't know if they'll maybe run into
each other at any any shows it's gonna
be interesting at the small world of
Hollywood that's what happened yes after
parties uh Amy's you guys what an
amazing amazing night that's just a
little case of the after parties for
full coverage of everything that went
down last night for the globe's and the
after parties be sure to tune in to
Entertainment Tonight tonight and also
head over to ET online.com we got it all
I mean we've been up a while Sophia says
I'm sad stranger things didn't win yeah
we didn't get any speeches from them and
I know that um David Harbor told me he
had a big long speech plan just like he
did it's more in show last year and so
many people saying oh brah
2020 okay um you guys all in all can we
just summarize by saying what an amazing
awards show because again we're talking
about these fun moments he's behind the
scene moments but the message of last
night was about women there was not one
celebrity who I saw who wasn't wearing
black and it was awesome and we are here
in black again today four times up I do
kind of walk away watching the Golden
Globes last night feeling very empowered
and I hope everyone stood to lose it was
an amazing night it was it was one for
the books I think and Daley Denny though
the people's champion you stayed up all
night doing the college getting this
together for everybody
yeah thank you guys so much for watching
this our first daily Denny live let us
know
what you thought in the comments section
below should we do more like this you
know it's kind of freely freestyle
little willy-nilly but I had a lot of
fun [ __ ] fun I could not believe I got
to be here Thank You Lauren so much for
being here and thank you guys so much
for watching be sure to like and comment
and share this video and I'll see you
tomorrow with a new episode of daily
Denny so stick around
bye guys
[Music]